[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I'm
going to keep my Preamble short because
I want to get into the meat and potatoes
of this conversation with my guest Brian
Armstrong he is the co-founder and chief
executive officer of coinbase founded in
2012. coinbase is building the crypto
economy a more fair accessible efficient
and transparent Financial system enabled
by crypto coinbase serves over 103
million verified users 14 500
institutions and 245 000 ecosystem
Partners in more than 100 countries in
April 2021 coinbase listed publicly on
the NASDAQ as coin before founding
coinbase Ryan served as a software
engineer at Airbnb where he focused on
fraud prevention before Airbnb Brian
founded and was CEO of
universitytutor.com and online tutoring
directory and a subsidiary of Johnson
educational Technologies LLC Brian also
served previously as a consultant for
the Enterprise risk management division
at Deloitte and touch LLP Brian as ba in
computer science and economics and an MS
in computer science from Rice University
over the last three years coinbase has
worked with 10-time Emmy award-winning
filmmaker Greg Koz on a documentary
about cryptocurrency and coinbase coin
that is the name of the documentary is
now available on Amazon iTunes Vimeo on
demand and other platforms you can find
Brian on Twitter which I suggest you
follow at Brian underscore Armstrong
Ryan nice to see you thanks for making
the time yeah thanks Tim for having me
on the show appreciate it sometimes in
the course of doing research I find a
gingerbread trail that leads me to the
story before the story before the story
and this may be a dead end but I'm going
to give it a shot
what was
startbreakingfree.com does this ring a
bell for you that's impressive you found
that
yeah so that that's a Blog that I
started and you know I actually decided
when I was right out of college I was
working on that Tutoring company somehow
I got the idea in my head that I should
write a book
and I think what I was doing was I was
whenever I want to try to learn
something or figure it out I try to
write it down now I just do blog posts
it seems a lot easier but at the time I
was like let me I really wanted to be an
entrepreneur I wanted to build a company
that was meaningful and you know most
people would probably go do that first
and then write the book but I somehow
got it backwards and was like you know
what let me write the book to figure out
how to do it so
I wrote a book called start breaking
free and then after I wrote this
I didn't have a publisher or anything I
was I was kind of doing a
self-publishing thing and I read a book
called How to Market your book and you
know I basically realized that I had to
go make a blog or something to try to
market the book so I started I created
this blog honestly the blog probably was
more impactful in my life than than the
book in the sense that I just put
something out every week I got reactions
from the audience in real time
so now my I guess my takeaway from that
was if I was going to do that again I'd
probably just go with a Blog and if I
had a Blog that had 10 or 12 15 posts
that had really resonated with people
I'd maybe later package those into a
book and add a few more that were unique
or something like that but yeah at the
time that was I got the order wrong and
I was just trying stuff so that's what I
put out there
sometimes it's the things you throw
against the wall that sort of in
retrospect form
the puzzle that helps you to do so many
things and I suppose one of the
experiences I'd love to at least bring
up since we have this shared time in
Argentina is your period of time in
Buenos Aires and it's hard for me to say
it that way in all scientists and I'd
like to hear specifically what you took
away
not just the experience of witnessing
hyperinflation which I do think we
should talk about but anything else that
struck you culturally or otherwise and
also why Argentina in the first place
of all the places you could go and and
if you could just Place Us in time in
terms of how old you are when in your
life this happens
I think I was probably 28 or 27
something in that time frame
and I graduated from college I'd been
working on this tutoring startup I tried
working at a couple different companies
like Deloitte you know frankly I wasn't
feeling very successful
I hadn't really found a company that I
wanted to work at I thought I wanted to
be an entrepreneur but the Tutoring
company I had started was kind of
limping along fairly successful I mean I
I was kind of paying my rent type thing
but barely and it wasn't really growing
and you know I had this sense of like
okay I want to go have some Adventure in
the world I want to learn how to do a
startup in a different way I had never
really tried living abroad like studying
abroad and there was part of me that was
like I just I need to grow up I need to
try something crazy and just get
Adventure in my life and I had never
been to South America and I knew a
little bit of Spanish from high school
but I was not very fluent at all and so
I decided you know what I'm gonna go do
a year spend a month in every major city
in South America travel around try to
find myself I was kind of doing like a
vision quest to figure out what I wanted
to do with my life and I can't remember
how I chose Buenos Aires but that was
intended to be my first destination of
of many one per month roughly
I think I just read some stuff online I
think you were I remember what time
frame you were down there but I think I
read your book maybe a couple of years
after that or something yeah timing was
kind of odd I basically made it down
there to Buenos Aires
didn't really have a place to stay or
anything I was intentionally kind of
throwing myself into like an unfamiliar
situation and you know I ended up
staying at a hostel I found finally a
room to rent I figured out how to use an
ATM got a local cell phone and after a
month I was finally settled a little bit
and I was like all right I don't want to
go have to do that all over again in
Brazil or Chile so I was like let me
stay here a little bit longer long story
short I ended up staying there about a
year and did a few trips into
neighboring countries and things like
that but mostly planted myself in Buenos
Aires and I don't know I guess the root
of your question is kind of like
what I took away from it I mean I can
tell you at the time I felt very lost
and in hindsight you can look back and
sort of connect some dots and like think
about oh hyperinflation and that kind of
stuff but I don't know one of the other
things I I guess I haven't talked about
before that I sort of realized while I
was there was that
you know the culture of that country was
just incredibly different from the US
right which is maybe an obvious
statement but the the thing that stood
out to me was that there wasn't optimism
about the future right people kind of
had this Vibe like keep your head down
you know don't do anything too crazy
because everything could get taken away
from you tomorrow and there was like I
saw a rampant corruption in various
places where you know businesses were
all kind of operating in the gray
occasionally there'd be like the Fire
official would come in and you know
quote close a restaurant for safety
issues but they were really trying to
get some payout it was kind of a gray
market and what I saw was I think what
happens when you have
a once great superpower right like
Argentina I think was like the eighth
largest economy in the world or
something in 1900
and then 100 years later you know it was
basically a hundred years of just
mismanagement corruption bad government
endless protests and the people sort of
misplaced their faith in the government
to do good things whereas ideally like
it would have been individuals
empowering themselves in free markets
and that is kind of in my belief What
hap what caused the United States to
this unique experiment in the United
States to really turn it into a world
superpower and so seeing the change of
optimism to pessimism in that country
just after 100 Years of you know bad
outcomes and feeling like you were
powerless that was something that did
sort of stick with me and so I hope it
doesn't come across too negative
Argentina has many beautiful things
about it as well culturally and I
learned many things just about valuing
like family and good food and
experiences and things like that but
from an optimism about the future point
of view it was it could not have been
more different
I can corroborate that I was in
Argentina 2004 to 2005 and so this was a
few years after the 2001 economic
meltdown which they seemed to almost
like clockwork have every you know five
to ten years which we could talk about
separately but the degree of apathy
was
jarring almost and I mean I do think
that for the portenos there's a the
people in in the in the capital
they're famous for complaining even by
the standards of the people in the
provinces so you have to take a little
bit of that along with things but
as you said there's there was very
little sense of optimism and I remember
talking to a shoe store owner who said
at one point you know the equivalent of
the first lady came in with security
guards shut down the store and just
grabbed anything that she wanted and she
was like thank you very much and walked
out of the store without paying and I
mean that I think
is a reflection of the broader
perception that people had of the
government and I remember walking around
in 2004 and still there was graffiti all
over the banks and which some of which
still had chains locking the doors shut
from when people were prevented from
withdrawing their cash savings
in panic mode because of hyperinflation
but the banks themselves effectively
close the doors and wouldn't allow them
to withdraw so you had vultures and
thieves and so on in Spanish on the
sides of all these Banks
let's hop to present day I mean I'm very
curious because I I think there are
many ways to spin apocalyptic scenarios
that are not all together likely but
when you look at the macroeconomic
climate currently we're recording this
in October of 2022.
are there any facets in particular that
you find concerning or think that people
are not paying enough attention to
in the broader economy I mean I don't
know the main thing I just I've been
thinking about a lot is Ray dalio's
recent book you know principles for a
changing World Order and I thought he
did a really good job of just kind of
looking back at history and teasing
apart some of these patterns and so when
I I found the book convincing you know I
haven't dug into the data myself he put
a lot of it online but it's not just
like his opinion he's trying to he's
trying to base it on facts of history
and I don't know my observation is that
I don't think America is in any kind of
like imminent danger of Rapid decline
but I do think it is in slow decline
that that part seems pretty likely to me
and so you see a lot of these telltale
signs of you know increasing
polarization and
like media starts to get more polarized
and captured by you know various
political organizations
we're seeing higher inflation obviously
and that's that's worrisome
you kind of go on down the list so you
know I think this particular moment
where whether we're in a recession or
not I my guess is that will be you know
something kind of like the 2008 crisis
or whatever which you know ironically is
the birth of Bitcoin and what came out
of that yeah so I don't think it'll be
massive in terms of like the whole you
know the US isn't like going to just
fall apart overnight but I do think it's
in slow Decline and so it raises a lot
of interesting questions about what is
the next World Order is that China is it
something that's going to be more
decentralized and internet-based
kind of like the network states that
biology has written about and I think
crypto probably has a big part to play
in this future because you know we
really are building a new economy the
crypto economy
it's more Global and decentralized and I
think a lot of people were thinking in
this current macro environment when we
saw High inflation hey maybe maybe
people will now go to bitcoin as the
the reserve currency or not the currency
but you know like the digital gold
equivalent and it didn't Bitcoin went
down along with the broader economy and
so it seems like people are still
treating Bitcoin as a growth Tech stock
equivalent or something
but my guess is that that's going to
change in the next five years or 10
years something like that and we will
start to see the crypto economy start to
become you know maybe over 10 or 20
years it'll become the main thing it's
sort of in the way that e-commerce back
20 years ago was sort of a sideshow but
now it's kind of the main thing and so I
think we'll see that happen with crypto
too
so let's rewind for a moment and then
we'll we'll go back and forth
chronologically because I I like the
Memento Style
of uh of conversation but if we go back
to very early decisions and V1 coinbase
so I watched the coin documentary which
I enjoyed a lot there's some raps I have
many questions and maybe we'll get to
later
related to being a private person but
also inviting a film crew to follow you
around especially in many of those
private contexts but yeah one of the key
moments appeared to be the decision to
put a buy Bitcoin button on coinbase so
I'd love for you to just paint a picture
for folks who may not know any of the
Genesis story
what the traction looked like what the
activity looked like for coinbase prior
to that and then most important or
interesting to me is
how you arrived at that decision
and thought about that decision and then
what happened afterwards
so before that decision to add the buy
Bitcoin button we had no traction really
things were flat and this is not
uncommon by the way in startups there is
something called the startup hype cycle
I think if you Google that you'll find
some Google images and it it beautifully
illustrates the process that a lot of
startups go through where you have this
kind of you launch and there's a big
spike and then it comes down to zero
because nobody cares they're just busy
with all the other stuff they're doing
in the world and you have kind of the
trough of sorrow and then you keep
working on the product and you you know
that's where a lot of startups die but
if you go through it you know usually
for like years you have to kind of do
this iteration of like talk to the
customer improve the product talk to the
customer improve the product and if you
don't die you don't get distracted you
don't get disillusioned you'll sometimes
see these like Wiggles of Hope and
eventually maybe if you're lucky you'll
find product Market fit and the thing
will take off so this is what they they
drill into you and you're when you go
through Y combinator which coinbase did
and it's sort of a startup incubator
where they teach you all these kind of
War Stories and so that's what I was
doing at this time as like a you know
aspiring entrepreneur I was I had
launched an early version of coinbase
just on Reddit and places like that you
know I'd gotten a couple hundred people
to come sign up and check it out and
then nobody would come back and so what
I did was I followed the Y combinator
advice and I emailed
I just emailed five of the people who
had signed up and I said hey I made this
this app I'd love to get your feedback
can I hop on the phone with you here's
my cell phone number
so I talked to five of these people and
I think it was like the third or fourth
person I was talking to
and the guy was like yeah I mean the app
seems cool and everything but like I
don't really have any Bitcoin so I just
signed up and then I didn't have any
Bitcoin I didn't come back and some kind
of light bulb this was like probably the
second or third person who had said
something like this and I I light bulb
went off in my head I was like well if
there was a buy
a buy button right in the app would you
have just done that and he was like yeah
probably because you know I don't know
it seems difficult like you have to wire
money to Japan there's the site Mount
gox I don't know it was too much of a
hassle so I just didn't do it so I went
about putting this simple buy button
basically as a hunch based on the user
feedback and it was it the button was
simple but the thing to actually get
that working was very difficult I mean
we basically I say we it was kind of
like just me at the time very shortly
thereafter Fred ursum joined and he he
and I co-founded it really but
you know I had to go find a bank partner
that would allow us to integrate with
the ACH Network in the US and convince
them what our anti-money laundering
policy was and then code up that
integration and you know make sure that
we were sourcing the Bitcoin once people
bought it anyway long story short we got
all that working and we launched a
simple buy button you could now connect
your bank account that was the first
time that had happened in the US where
you could connect a payment method and
just buy Bitcoin really simply and
that's the moment we had product Market
fit it started to grow organically every
every week after that and it was like a
boulder we were chasing downhill I think
I I think I say that in the film as well
yeah goes from pushing pushing the
boulder uphills to chasing it downhill
yeah what was the timing on that was
that late 2012 when would that have been
yeah that you implemented that button
probably late 2012 early 2013 was right
around then yeah that would have been
also exactly at the encouragement of
Kevin rose that I bought my first
Bitcoin on coinbase would have been
literally
few months after that button was
introduced so yeah thanks for that yeah
actually I went I did an interview with
Kevin I think right around that time I
did interview him at his house and uh I
think that that's a fun interview to go
back and look at too but yeah crazy
times he makes a cameo in the dock as
well which you may or may not know but
I'm sure he'll be I'm sure he'll be
pleased with so I'd like to talk about
influences
and maybe we'll start with a a shared
a shared figurehead and that is Richard
Feynman so I've I've read quite a few of
your blog posts and you've written about
books that have had an impact on you or
that you recommend to others one of them
is surely you're joking Mr Feynman
that's That's a classic
on my bookshelf that I revisit pretty
often there's a lot of backstory there
let's begin with that book is there
anything about Feynman or that book that
that really stands out to you or you
would reflect to people who are not
familiar with the book and then what
other books come to mind that have had a
maybe a disproportionate impact on your
thinking or that you've simply gifted a
lot or recommended much to other people
that book definitely did stand out to me
and
I think I think the thing that was
exciting about it was he was just had
this kind of curiosity for life and a
you know Boundless Energy to go try
different things and Tink around and
experiment and I guess what I loved
about that was I mean first of all it's
just it's just funny it's quite a
humorous book
but I guess what I loved about it was
like it gave you this kind of zest for
life of like never stop learning always
be curious and also just you can kind of
treat life like it's a video game right
like other other people have talked
about this that this is not my original
stuff but I think there is something to
that where if you stop taking life so
seriously and you realize anything
around you you know there was like that
Steve Jobs quote like everything around
you was made by somebody else who just
decided like you don't have to just
consume the world the world is not
happening to you you can go create
things in the world right and so once
you start to think of it like that it
really changes your perspective like
just one example would be
if you're going through something really
difficult
you might start to get kind of down
right you're like oh man this sucks and
this person hates me and I'm I'm losing
on this or whatever but if you start to
think about if life was a video game you
know the hardest part of the game might
be like kind of the most interesting or
the most fun it's like the part that you
really need to pull together and anyway
it just changes your your perspective
entirely
you asked about other books too I mean
let's see I already mentioned dalio's
Book Changing world order I thought that
was good I've gifted that to a handful
of people
you know I think Milton Friedman has
this book called free to choose I
actually have never read the book but
there was a TV series he did on PBS back
in the day
that was also called free to choose and
I thought that was kind of interesting I
mean it's it's kind of libertarian so
some people will like that some people
won't but I I found it actually quite
interesting just to like get his view on
sort of the global macro environment in
different countries and how they work
and that was something I've also gone
back to look at once in a while I think
it did influence my thinking in
hindsight
I want to come back to something you
said which was talk to the customer
iterate talk to the customer iterate and
just to maybe State the obvious which is
very often
entrepreneurs try to iterate without
talking to the customer and one of the
things I appreciate about many of the
founders who've gone through y
combinator this includes the Airbnb
Founders and others is in the early days
doing things that don't scale
right really taking a manual approach to
interacting with customers what else
would you consider core principles or
learnings that you took away from y
combinator or polygram specifically or
anyone else involved
well I don't know if this came up in
your research but actually I worked at
Airbnb before starting coinbase so yes
indeed yeah I mean I was I think it was
Employee 40 there or something like that
and then I got to learn a lot from them
too about yeah the perseverance and how
they ran product and all it was really
cool but I guess some of the lessons
just generally from that that ecosystem
because it all came from by combinator
and Airbnb and all that stuff
I mean another one of my favorite kind
of polygramisms is
action produces information right so
there's many times where you're sitting
around and you're like all right well
what if this happens what if that
happens and you're kind of staring into
the abyss like into the cloud the fog
ahead of you and you don't really know
what to do and so people sometimes get
stuck in those environments and they
just they never take any action
basically but if you just take some
steps into the unknown you might not be
doing the right thing but oftentimes by
doing that action you'll realize what
you should have been doing instead there
was a great story that kind of went
along with this where the early days of
coinbase uh actually before it was even
called coinbase I was just tinkering on
some stuff nights and weekends while I
was at Airbnb and I remember
um I built this very simple app with a
friend of mine I think it was just
called Bitcoin wallet or something it
may still be on GitHub somewhere but it
was basically an Android app and we
decided hey we want to make
we want to make like a Bitcoin wallet
that runs on Android it was supposed to
be very simple right and we didn't have
any kind of cloud thing behind it it
wasn't any sort of a company or anything
like that and so we basically ran a full
Bitcoin node right on the Android phone
which at the time people might laugh at
it now but at the time Bitcoin nodes
were very small and lightweight and they
could run on phones and
so we coded this thing up and we
launched it I was just trying stuff I
didn't know what I was doing we weren't
even trying to make a company we were
just kind of like trying to learn this
stuff in the evenings in our free time
and I launched it I remember the minute
that we launched it that was like wired
wrote some little article about it I was
like wow that's so cool wired wrote an
article about it but the minute we
launched it I realized we had built it
wrong and the reason I realized that was
that we were trying to again we were
running the whole Bitcoin node right on
the phone and it would take forever like
every time you open the app it would say
syncing and it would have to sync like
for three four minutes or whatever to
catch up with the latest blockchain
blocks and so that was a good example
where like I knew it instantly we'd
built the wrong thing and then what went
off in my head was okay someone's gonna
have to make a company around this that
has a truly like a lot of this stuff
running in the cloud where you can do
all the backups and security and sync
with the blockchains and and I was I
remember thinking at that time oh that's
not going to be me because I have a day
job and like that's a really serious
company to run and someone will probably
try to hack into it and it's like you
got to have like a lot of money for that
so I didn't I didn't immediately get to
the next step was maybe I'll start that
company but it that was a good example
of just taking action produced
information which made the next step a
little bit more clear
do you have any favorite essays by Paul
I have one bookmarked that I reread
often I mean he's got so many good
essays but the top idea in your mind not
that you should be familiar with that
one but that that's one since I have a
creative project that I'm focused on at
the moment that I revisit with some
regularity yeah any favorite essays or
other Paul Graham isms that come to mind
you know there's so many good ones I
think people should read them all but
there's one about I think it's about how
to how to build wealth or something it
just really nicely explains the idea
where people think money is zero sum
it's like well for me to have money you
have to you have to take it from
somebody else so it's like inherently
evil and he's like no you know if you
just like assemble a bunch of things
either natural resources or you improve
a car I think is the way he described it
he's like you haven't made anybody else
worse off like you you made the mechanic
better off and like when you sell the
you know but you made yourself better
off in the process and so value is not
Zero Sum I think that's really important
for people to understand and once in a
while I go back and read his essay I
think it's called haters whenever I'm
feeling down like people are whenever I
accidentally read the comments online
which is not a good idea that's a good
one to go back and read too amazing I'm
looking at two of them so haters that's
January 2020 and then I think this is
the wealth essay which is how to make
wealth from May 2004 which originally
came from his book hackers and Painters
so I will put both of those in the in
the show notes so let's talk about
sort of psycho emotional response to
outside scrutiny or criticism for a
second because
what is what is covered quite
extensively in the dock and certainly
was covered even more extensively in the
news was your decision not that long ago
to offer a generous Severance packages
to people who
disagreed with your statements about
coinbase as a mission-driven company
that provides a refuge of sorts with
that Focus that and please
correct my description if it doesn't fit
but and in so being a mission-driven
company wanting to avoid
sort of political and social
conversations within the company that
that chew up time and energy and
resources and attention
feel free to to set the table a little
better than I did but can you describe
the situation
the action
and then what is what is of greatest
interest to me is how you thought about
making the decision how you thought
about the possible ramifications of
making that decision and
prepared yourself
for what might happen and then what did
happen just weathering that
a few years back we put out this blog
post that coinbase was going to become a
mission focused company which basically
meant we were going to be a political
not focus on broader societal issues in
the workplace and so how did that all
come to be I mean really I'd say for the
couple of years prior to that
there was something that was sort of
bubbling up inside the company which
initially was very slow and subtle and I
didn't really pay too much attention to
it but eventually it culminated in a
walkout a bunch of employees being so
upset that they kind of closed their
laptops and decided not to come into
work in protest and that was sort of the
a big moment in the company history
because that had never happened before
and so what what led up to that well
that basically there was a lot of you
know covet happened people were at home
they were probably had less of a sense
of belonging and cohesion as hey we're
all one company we're one group of
people we're all trying to do good stuff
in the world so there was a little bit
of frustration there there was probably
a lack of cohesion there and then I'd
say there just it became more popular in
society I've since gone back and read
some books on this like um you know
Jonathan Heights book about the
colleague of American mind and all these
things that kind of started on college
campuses I I sort of loosely read a few
things here and there about this but I
never really took it that seriously I
figured this was just you know there's
always been activism on college campuses
whatever we're trying to build something
in our company I didn't pay much
attention to it but what happened was we
started to get
basically more activism inside the
company whereas like initially I was
always thinking hey we're on the same
team we've got competitors we've got
Regulators we've got we're trying to
create all this change we're all on the
same team and internally people started
to think actually we're not all on the
same team my job is not to help the
coinbase mission it's to hold you know
speak truth to power or to hold this
other team you know to account or
something like that and so it manifested
in strange ways like at the Town Hall
meetings that we'd have every two weeks
we don't have an open mic q a and more
and more of the questions started to be
about things not really related to what
we were building as a company but to
about broader societal issues and it
almost became this this like thing where
who could make the exec team squirm the
most on stage and you know with these
very difficult questions and of course I
didn't have great answers to many of the
biggest broader societal issues we were
trying to all focus on building a more
more economic freedom in the world so as
I was noticing this was happening this
was around the time of the George Floyd
riots and everything like that and the
murder there and so there was a moment I
think where somebody in one of the All
Hands kind of came up and said um is
coinbase going to publicly support black
lives matter and I basically deferred to
answer the question I hadn't really read
that much about it I was like we're
gonna go look at this I don't know
to be determined and that wasn't good
enough and they kind of held the mic and
they pressed the issue and this is where
a bunch of people walked out of the
company so this was I was frankly
shocked I was like At first I was just
so surprised we all got in a room as an
exec team
and I I was like what I don't understand
what does coinbase have to do with
police brutality like we're not we're
not related to this but of course
this thing was erupting all over
societies all over the world and people
just felt every company every person
ever had to make some kind of a stand on
this and so it was a very difficult
leadership moment I remember calling
some people into the room telling me and
asking them what does BLM actually stand
for if we're going to go out there and
like say something positive about it and
you know they're like well it's
basically equality for you know people
and I was like great okay if that's what
people want to hear I don't understand
it but let's let's go out there and say
it and so I basically went out and made
a statement supporting BLM as many
companies did at that time and um people
came back to work which was fine but as
the months ticked by I started to feel
increasingly uneasy about it first of
all I subsequently learned that BLM
supported other things like around
defunding the police and all these
things which I was like all right we
shouldn't be getting involved in those
issues I I don't know what our point of
view is on that and I I basically
realized there was not a clear
agreement amongst all the people in the
company that some people felt the
company should actually be engaging in
broader societal issues to try to go
help out and other people felt that we
should be focused on our mission which
was a very big and important thing
already
increasing economic freedom in the world
with crypto and I was in that ladder
camp and I felt like that's already a
big enough thing to focus on we can't be
jumping to every issue of of the month
or the year we have to try to focus it
might take 10 20 years for us to make a
dent in that problem that's a really big
thing
so I realized the company was divided on
this issue and I was kind of failing as
a leader if I didn't come out and make
it clear and so I basically after a
couple months of deliberating and this
is where you're asking about my thought
process I was really torn about this
this is where I sat down to write and I
tried to write a blog post because when
I try to formulate my thinking I try to
write so I wrote probably two or three
or four drafts of this where I just
discarded it and tried to write it over
again and I was reading books talking to
people at this time I eventually settled
on this language Around Mission first
and I remember
sharing it with some leaders inside the
company and with our board and there
were some people inside the company who
were like you know do not share this
under any circumstances this is this
will be a terrible thing for the company
and I was like I know it's going to be
controversial but we have to solve this
problem right like I don't really care
so much about a couple bad headlines I
care if we're are we building an aligned
culture that can actually accomplish
this Mission long term
and some people told me things like you
know an underrepresented person will
never work at this company again and I
was like really is that true I went and
talked to some of our employee resource
groups and they told me I asked them
what's the most important thing to you
want to work at this company they're
like we just want to be respected at
work like learn things be able to build
cool stuff it was basically what
everybody else wanted and so from
talking with people directly my hunch
was that was not going to actually play
out but that was a fear people had and I
think the thing that finally pushed me
over the line to do it because I'm kind
of a conflict diverse person by Nature I
didn't really want to be known for this
but I think the thing that pushed me
over the line was I was thinking like
God like the CEO job is just not that
fun to be honest like if I have to come
in every day and be put in front of the
hot mic and like have to answer all
these crazy things that I don't have an
answer to
that's not what I signed up for I want
to build cool stuff with technology that
changes the world that's what I'm good
at and so I was basically thinking like
either I have to go if this is just what
the job of being a tech CEO is in modern
day I've got to go because this is not
fun for me or they've got to go and from
talking to a couple of friends and
mentors and whatnot I basically realized
they've got to go and it was strange
because it felt like such a vocal it
felt like maybe it was 50 of the company
or something but it wasn't it was a very
vocal tiny percentage of the company and
so I basically made this exit package
available I said look this is the
direction we're going in if you're not
if you're not okay with that I totally
get it I didn't make it clear up front
that's my fault so we're gonna give this
great severance package whatever five
percent of the company left
it created a bunch of drama for a few
months a couple journalists wrote hit
pieces on us and things like that but
afterwards it was it was better it was
like one of the best things I've ever
done for the company to be honest
because now we're fully aligned we're
making faster progress everybody who
joins the company knows what they're
signing up for and it was an incredibly
important leadership moment for me
because I was terribly scared to do do
it I didn't want the controversy I knew
it was people were going to hate it
and so yeah hopefully that gives some
clarity no it does and it just for
clarity hopefully you don't feel I'm
asking this question to make you squirm
that's not the objective I'm genuinely
curious about the thought process
surrounding what is inevitably on some
level going to be an unpopular decision
right and I think that is a Hallmark of
good leadership otherwise I mean you're
just taking votes and consensus and
doing what the larger
group would do anyway right so it seems
to me that integral to effective
leadership is
having the ability to make
unpopular decisions when it is in the
best interest long term of the company
and the mission in this case right yeah
that is that is why I asked so thank you
for answering totally I was chatting
with
Katie Han who's a mutual mutual friend
and certainly as
played a role continues to play a role
with client base and
you know she phrased it I think very
well I'm looking at some notes here and
she effectively said that
you seem to embody this kind of sticks
and stones may break my bones but words
will never hurt me
set of attributes or at least you seem
from the outside unfazed by
criticism or a lot of criticism and I'm
not asking you to Bear your soul and
tell me about all the things that have
hurt your feelings also also don't want
to give people
the sort of directions on uh how to
attack you effectively but I am curious
if that is something you have to what
extent is that something you have
developed and cultivated if that's even
an accurate perception
that definitely is something that I've
cultivated I don't think I was naturally
that way
I'm probably more sort of steady than
than the average person but I definitely
have you know ups and downs and a lot of
stuff has really affected me over the
years so I think it's a skill people can
learn and develop and it's a muscle that
gets stronger and stronger basically
there's something that was very
counterintuitive to me I assume that
when starting a company there'd be many
hard things you know raising money
finding product Market fit even just
bunch of people being skeptical that it
would ever work I kind of anticipated
all of that
what I didn't anticipate was that people
would actually root for you to fail or
actually misunderstand someone's
intentions and think that they were bad
or evil or whatever whatever that would
be and um that was surprising you know
if you're just like a normal person
which I am as well you've gone about
your life you know you try to you know
you're not going to make everybody happy
but you're basically a good person you
try to do whatever it's kind of rare you
know maybe once in a while someone get
upset with you or something you go
smooth it over
I had never had the experience of having
like a thousand or a hundred thousand
people mad at you at the same time you
know which is like a very uncomfortable
thing the first few times it happens
and you know I would respond to the
stress of it just you know I wouldn't
oftentimes I wouldn't be able to sleep
it well at night
I would kind of wake up or like in the
middle of the night with these like
stress dreams or
just like ruminate on these things you
know it's it's not great right and so
I don't know I think I developed some
strategies for sort of coping with it
over time I mean one of them is that
again I try not to read the comments
right it's really it's really true like
whether it's like Twitter or Hacker News
or
even
a lot of stuff just notifications coming
on your phone whatever there's a moment
every day where you have your own time
and mental energy ready and your
calendar is cleared and I really feel
like you've got to tune out all that
[ __ ] and basically think about if I
only got one or two things done today
that would actually Advance what I want
to get done in the world what would that
be
you know turn off your phone turn off
and all that stuff and just try to get
the one or two things done that you want
to get done that day and then later you
can you can turn on your phone and read
some stuff if you want to do some
self-flatulation you know
and so there's a real art to like
preserving your mental focus I think
that's like the most valuable scarce
resource you have and so you have to
kind of really preserve that
you don't want to isolate yourself so
much that you're not getting feedback
from people because then you can just
become like reclusive or you know turn
into Putin or whatever I don't know you
want to make sure you're getting input
from people that have your best
interests at heart right my family you
know they don't treat me as they don't
defer to me at all they're just like uh
you know whatever take out the trash you
want to have your board be like that you
want to have your friends be like that
you know my co-founder Fred ursum and
now like Emily Choi who's the president
CEO we have that relationship or she can
she can just tell me like Brian you're
being an idiot like don't do that you
know
and so you always want to have people
around you that have your best interests
at heart and can tell you when you're
being an idiot that's very important but
you don't there's a lot of other people
that are playing their own game that
don't have their best interest at heart
they're trying to build their own status
game and some virtue signaling thing
they're trying to get clicks on their
article
whatever they're trying to do and you
don't really need to listen to that
stuff in fact it's like really harmful
to your progress if you are listening to
that stuff so there's a real art of just
tuning that out and caring less I guess
is there any other advice that you would
give or perhaps you have given of course
you're very involved in the
entrepreneurial ecosystem and you know I
have to imagine that you invest in some
startups and private companies although
you can correct me if I'm wrong what
advice
would you give to someone who is in a
company that is beginning to scale and
they're starting to get hit with the
hundreds then a thousand people or maybe
it's just 10
opportunistic journalists who are really
just kind of Smashing The Rock Against
the head of this poor startup because it
gets a lot of clicks what advice
would you give to this person or what
might you might you say to them
one thing I always remember is that if
you go talk to other CEOs
they're all going through the same thing
but you haven't read any of their other
articles right yeah I remember talking
to a friend recently Bobby codic at
Activision he's been getting all this
negative press about whatever I actually
hadn't seen any of the Articles the
negative articles about it and but for
him it's like well he was kind of at the
center of this storm and whatever he's a
great guy he's going to pull through it
but it just made me realize like wow
he's at the center of this hurricane and
I hadn't even heard about it I'm too
busy to do my own world doing my own
thing and that's what's true of like 99
of people they don't they see some
article whatever like there's a million
things that they're thinking about they
don't they actually don't care that much
about whatever the thing is that feels
so existential and awful to you
the other thing I would just say is like
it's a rite of passage honestly like you
should celebrate it right like if the
first time you get a New York Times hit
piece or whatever I mean congratulations
you earned your wings as an entrepreneur
and the moment that you realize
it didn't really matter and you can kind
of keep doing whatever you think is good
in the world and
you've actually you level up like you
kind of earn your stripes and you become
a more powerful CEO because you're like
okay I'm not gonna make a decision in
the company based on how I'm afraid of
how other people react I'm going to do
what I think is best for the long term
of the company and so that's actually a
superpower I think it's great when
people go through it and even when it
feels like [ __ ] I'm like congratulations
you just made it to the next level
I like the reframe it makes me all the
more I want to read this uh this haters
piece by Paul Graham also
how do you think about
and this is related to Paul Graham in a
sense in the building wealth and the the
non-zero-sum game of wealth creation in
many capacities right so looking at
things from a lens of abundance rather
than scarcity but
this brings me to the question of
competition how do you think about
competition I know that seems very broad
but I'm going to leave it Broad and just
see where it goes
on the one hand
I you know I've got some competitive
Spirit too and I I think it's like
useful to have competitors it actually
makes us better it gets it gets me fired
up it gets the team fired up like
honestly if you don't have a competitor
people are naturally tribalistic you'll
sometimes get tribes will start to form
inside the company and like people start
fighting each other and so that's it's
actually better to have like something
outside the company that you're
struggling against on the other hand
like it's just too much focus on
competitors you should almost ignore it
like another polygramism you know is
like startups die by Suicide not
homicide and that's kind of a gory thing
to say but what he means of course is
that companies blow up because they're
bureaucratic or the the founders have
some big fight or the board you know has
some drama and they run out of money or
whatever they die due to dysfunction
internally it has it's almost never
because some competitor directly hurt
you it's like you just get out executed
because you're so focused on the wrong
things
and so I think that's very true and
especially like in the crypto space you
know we have lots of really great
competitors around the world and you
know I think it's good that we're
competing with them we get fired up but
like ultimately I care a lot more about
how do we grow the size of the pie 100x
than I do like trying to win a few
points of share from some other company
in crypto so I try to mostly just be
friends with the other companies that
are ostensibly competitors I try to stay
friends with those CEOs and just
learn from each other and you know sure
we're competing but we're all trying to
grow the size of the crypto economy 100x
and that's how I think about it
there are several directions that I want
to go and I'm trying to pick the the
most appropriate Direction
well here we go
in today's climate
what do you think
the crypto Bears or Skeptics most miss
or should pay attention to and
conversely the the manic bowls
on uh let's just say nft and crypto
Twitter
what are they most missing about the
landscape or should they pay more
attention to
like the extreme Skeptics and the
die-hard you know
fill in the blank or die crypto
aficionados
sort of common theme my personalities I
try to reject tribalism uh and so I'm I
try to you know it's Never As Good As It
Seems never as bad as it seems in crypto
neither side is is correct so I guess
what the the Skeptics of crypto Miss is
that
this is early days right it's kind of
like if you had looked at the internet
in 1999 or 2000 you might say ah dial-up
modems are kind of slow it's too clunky
to use for the average person why would
I go read an article online when I get
the newspaper delivered every day
you know you can't trust anything that
you read on the Internet it's full of
scams and people writing crazy things on
their blogs and
and so they're looking at it through the
lens of well compare it to the
traditional Financial system in every
aspect today but they're not seeing what
the potential of it is and and the
fundamental underlying technology is
something that's inherently more Global
and can be more efficient and fair and
free and and so anyway they're not
seeing the potential
I guess the people who are insane crypto
Bulls are just I think they're basically
too focused on getting rich quick I mean
it's not just you know everyone's trying
to like find some Shortcut or whatever
and like pump something or buy it and
flip it and I just think there's no free
lunches in life and um
go do the hard work of building
something actually useful and take a
longer term perspective and that's where
you'll see real value emerge and by the
way it's not to say that crypto is all
is like it's all future potential value
I think a lot of people miss that today
too they're like well what are the use
cases well you know there's a lot of
people using crypto today not just for
trading they're using it you know to
make art and to make payments to each
other in different countries and you
know to raise money and to do games and
like so there's tons of people actually
using it for real stuff already
borrowing and lending and earning a
living and paying for tasks and
earning yield on their assets and all
kinds of stuff like that so we one of
the metrics we track at coinbase is kind
of what percent of our active customers
are doing something with crypto other
than trading and that number used to be
like 10 maybe three or four years ago
now it's I think over 50 percent of our
active customers are doing something
other than just trading with crypto and
yeah so it's emerging if you were to
take that pie chart of other doing other
things with crypto what are the main
slivers
the the use cases so again it's not just
one but it's it's a it's a mix of a
bunch of things so it's per people
earning yield on their assets with
things like staking it's people doing
Commerce with crypto it's people buying
and selling minting nfts D5 has been a
really big use case as well
some of that by the way is trading
there's decentralized exchanges but it's
not all that it's it's other aspects of
D5
things like coinbase card have been
really useful in terms of getting people
using crypto in the real world brick and
mortar or online anywhere that visas
accepted they can spend crypto so we're
seeing that as a emerging use case
coinbase earn is like another one that
we've seen that's that's driven a lot of
that that activity so
yeah peer-to-peer payments it's a bunch
of things so I'm going to come back to
Art and nfts momentarily but first just
to return to the the skeptic question
and you mentioned it's still early days
if you wanted to use
data to make that argument
and that I suppose this will be slightly
outside the purview of data but if you
also want to talk about maybe watershed
moments or shifts that are either in
progress or that you anticipate as
almost inevitable that still haven't
happened that should accelerate things
how would you make the case
with with data or anticipated shifts
that haven't yet happened and to just to
speak for a second to the second portion
of that question I know this is a long
question
I remember
as I mentioned to first started buying
Bitcoin 2000 late 2012 early 2013 have
been involved since quietly doing my
thing
and there are a lot of good reasons for
the quietly part but yeah I remember
watching some of the early hedge funds
getting involved and taking crypto
positions and I was like okay that's
very interesting and uh and so I started
to ask myself well they're some of their
LPS you know the limited partners are
these institutional investors whether
they're endowments or Pension funds or
fill in the blank and I started asking
what would it take for those types of
institutional players to begin to
allocate even a tiny tiny tiny
percentage of their total assets under
management to crypto
and then I started asking well what
would need to happen What would this
what social proof would be required for
a sovereign wealth fund to then allocate
a small sliver to crypto assets and it
just seemed
uh inevitable is a strong word but
highly likely that there would be a
certain Cascade of events and that's how
I kind of backed into maybe because uh
just uh what do they call it pumping my
bags right because I have a vested
interest uh so you know there might be a
bias there but if you want to make the
case to the Skeptics that actually like
let me show you a couple of slides let
me show you a couple of historical
examples this is why I can make the case
that it's early
how would you do it
I guess going to your first point I
agree crypto adoption is kind of
following a similar trajectory of like
internet adoption and there's probably
200 250 million people or so in the
world who have crypto now and we can
probably share a link that kind of shows
a similar chart kind of with the
internet and and I think that's
important and then to your point about
you know Sovereign wealth funds and
these a lot of I think like 90 of the
wealth in the world is actually blocked
up in institutions so we we analyzed
that early on and we realized okay we
had to launch an Institutional product
and coinbase Prime and which we have
actually been successful at getting more
and more of these large institutions to
move starting to move the percentages of
their portfolios into crypto
that includes I I don't think we've been
able to announce any of these yet but
there's I know of at least there are
some Sovereign wealth funds out there
that have now done it and we've closed
these deals with like BlackRock and like
the largest asset manager in the world
to kind of get more and more of this
money flowing in and there was a bunch
of work that went on behind the scenes
of that so what what are the major
inflection points that can cause that to
happen I mean
the biggest one I think in my mind is
regulatory Clarity you know that's the
one that when I talk to institutional
investors yeah they always bring that up
and the good news is we're starting to
finally see regulatory Clarity and we
can talk about what that is if you want
and I think even more regulatory Clarity
in the next year or two will actually
drive a bunch more of that money the
other major inflection point that I
focus on is scalability of the
blockchains because very similar again
to the internet with dial-up moving to
broadband
the initial blockchains you know I think
Bitcoin was doing about seven
transactions per second ethereum was
doing 25 transactions a second and you
know basically like PayPal does about
500 transactions a second Visa does
about 4 000 a second so we needed a
couple orders of magnitude to get to
like those more Visa levels which in
computer science you know an order of
magnitude is not that crazy so it's it's
actually easier than it sounds probably
so the good news is we're starting to
see that things like ethereum's merge
that just happened has been an
incredible technical accomplishment
and I think the future pieces that
they're going to launch with that are
going to improve the scalability even
further with sharding and things like
that so we're finally starting to see
the blockchain and other blockchains
have been working a lot of really great
scalability stuff too salon and others
so I think we're seeing
the lightning Network you know all the
L2 stuff so we're seeing a lot of really
good Focus now happening on
scalability of the blockchain so the
regulatory Clarity scalability to
blockchains to me that's like we'll
probably get another order of magnitude
or more out of that just those two
things alone
so let me ask you a question on the path
to my head which which might be a
ridiculous question but maybe that's my
specialty if you were
getting started right now with the
technical shops and know-how that you
have including the the expertise you've
developed the management capabilities
Etc at coinbase but you could not work
coinbase
nonetheless you had to remain in loosely
speaking the crypto web 3 world let's
just say
is there a company that you would put on
your short list for where you would work
or a type of company
maybe focusing on a specific aspect of
any of these technical pieces
well I can tell you there's like
certainly some cool ideas in in crypto
that I would consider doing I mean maybe
that's like kind of the root of your
question it is yeah like I think thanks
for translating my very convoluted
questions of Simplicity I was trying to
think what our comms team would would
think if I was like you know I'd really
love to work at this other crypto
company like what what the hell happened
no but uh abort abort yeah they teach
you in the pr training noise pivot the
question to the one you wish was asked
you know that's a good question let me
tell you a story that's unrelated yeah
exactly
um decentralized identity is really cool
I think once we have it's already
starting to happen but once we have
canonical identities it makes payments
easier it makes reputation easier it
makes decentralized social media easier
there's probably a lot of stuff there
decentralized social media I think could
be a big one could you give an example
of decentralized identity are we talking
about like ens are we talking about
something else ens is probably the most
well-known standard right now but
there's a handful of poses out there and
it's you know the simple way to think of
it is like the internet initially people
were using IP addresses to sort of like
connect and then then we got domain
names and so the domain name is like
human readable you can have like Tim
ferriss.com and you know that IP address
is a machine readable
so right now Bitcoin addresses and
ethereum mattresses they look machine
readable they're kind of these long
random strings of characters they look
like a giant password or something it's
impossible for humans to really remember
them or even know if you're setting it
to the right spot so we're getting
closer and closer to having
like kind of human readable names
everywhere and ens is a really big piece
of that so actually like with coinbase
wallet we recently um set this up where
anybody can go in there and claim a free
ens name you can get like
tim.cb.id at the end and try to make
that super simple if people if people
can buy their own as well and get like
you know tim.eth but we'll give you a
free one with the cb.id on the end if
you want so anyway long way of saying I
think decentralized identity is a big
piece of the ecosystem that'll come
together in the crypto economy I think
we need to have a currency that's
actually not linked to Fiat right like
we have USD coin which is really great
it's kind of backed one to one by US
dollar and there's decentralized stable
coins like like die but it'd be nice to
have like a stable coin or a flat coin
that's actually linked to purchasing
power
kind of like you know if you if one coin
buys you a McDonald's hamburger today
hopefully in five years you know one
coin will buy you a McDonald's hamburger
again yeah and there's various ways you
can imagine constructing that
yeah there's a lot of ideas I think like
I keep thinking about how
we could get crypto stored at various
latitudes and longitudes like I don't
know did you ever see like Pokemon go
how people had these like AR experiences
and they could kind of like geocache
things and go find them and anyway
there's lots of cool stuff we could
probably do I'll give you like three
more ideas if you want but I'll pause
there sure yeah no let's do it let's do
three more ideas okay well by the way
these are I don't want to take credit
for these I was talking with lots of
random people but
I think there's an opportunity to do
something with media and crypto where
you know a lot of articles are out there
be nice to have a community come
together probably backed by a crypto
coin that sort of helps it's a reward
coin you know that helps people kind of
fact check articles develop sort of
truthiness scores on every article
publication journalist out there I think
that that could be a nice like community
that comes together there should
probably be kind of like a stripe Atlas
for crypto in the sense that a lot of
people are and some people are doing
this they're trying to make make it
easier for people to create a a company
uh like a dow would sort of be like the
new Delaware C Corp if you will
but just make that whole thing of like
issuing a token managing a coin table
payroll you know fundraising like all
that stuff could probably be powered in
sort of a new kind of app
there should probably be like jobs in
marketplaces all based around crypto
kind of like you know eBay for crypto
Elance for crypto Amazon for crypto all
that stuff so a lot of stuff out there
that could probably be worked on and I
think we're seeing so many Venture
dollars go into crypto it's kind of
remarkable I think even in the down
Market oh it's mind-boggling yeah it's
it's a lot and it's probably like five
or ten billion dollars of dry powder
inventure right now to ready to go to
crypto startups so that's a rough
estimate somebody might have a better
one but it's it's a lot so yeah let me
take away from that back to
art slash nfts and I recognize nfts are
not solely the domain of
art or expensive jpegs but you know I
happen to be very interested in this
world for a number of reasons one of
which being I the the jpegs slash
parallels with Contemporary Art I think
just provide a nice on-ramp for a lot of
people who would otherwise be
intimidated by
blockchain Technologies and so on to
become part of the ecosystem
but let me ask you specifically what did
you learn from the launch of your nft
Marketplace
what are some of the learnings from that
I'll talk about sort of nfts generally
for a second and then what I guess the
empty Marketplace we did specifically so
so nfts I think are are going to be a
big thing in crypto and obviously these
initial use cases around Collectibles
and art has been great in a in one sense
but I think the idea of entities is
actually much bigger than that yeah you
know I could be representing any unique
digital item like in the metaverse right
it could be like property in the
metaverse your spaceship your clothes
whatever the metaphors
it could be people kind of issuing
concert tickets that are digitally
unique right it could be
people doing like citizenship in certain
like I actually got an nft that was for
the city Dao in Wyoming which is like
this plot of land that they divided up
and I think I have like access rights or
voting rights or something like now with
my passport which is this provably
digital thing right so I think art and
actually getting creators paid because a
lot of a lot of creative people like
have really bad contracts with you know
record labels and all these things so
just getting all the creative stuff
going is like a huge thing in itself but
it's actually going to be even bigger
beyond that
and then okay so yeah coinbase launched
uh coinbase nft and just like all things
we want to make it easier for people
like we know that we noticed what people
were doing often was that coming to
coinbase buying crypto
and then they would have to kind of move
it to like a Chrome extension in their
browser visit one of the many other apps
out there which are all very good and
good things to say about them we've
invested in some of them
but then it's just kind of like a hard
convoluted process especially once you
introduce like these Layer Two Solutions
like sometimes you'd have to bridge your
you'd have to buy ethereum move it to
the Chrome extension Bridge it to
polygon you know like people were like
losing their their nfts because and they
don't understand how to manage their
passwords and these things so this is an
example where the thing that coinbase
always tries to do is we just try to
make crypto more trusted and easier to
use that's like kind of our brand like
all the all the products that we've made
are just like let's make it more trusted
let's make it easier to use for the
average person
so we figured all right people are they
already have some crypto on coinbase
they've already got their identity and
all that connected let's just give them
a bunch of nfts there that they can
click a buy button so with coinbase nft
we've we've now launched that the very
first version of it is out there which
nft.coinbase.com we're doing it some
work now to kind of more deeply
integrate it right into the the actual
main coinbase app so that you don't
really have to go to a separate website
you can just click buy right in there
we're also doing something where
this is kind of what's cool about
blockchains in general is that a lot of
the
other marketplaces out there they're all
built on these open protocols and so
we've what we've done is we've actually
aggregated the supply out there of
basically wherever people are selling
their their nfts it'll all be exposed in
uh coinbase nft and so and if you click
buy it'll transact in that Marketplace
will get their fee right so in other
words we don't necessarily want to be so
competitive with these other
marketplaces as much as just
provide a simple trusted interface and
if they were the ones who put out the
smart contract for that and that's where
the customers are listing it
so be it like you know we'd want to like
kind of make it simple for people to
transact regardless of where it the
supply aggregated from so there's a few
things like that that we're doing that I
hope will just make kind of nfts even
easier for people to collect and own and
buy and sell and
yeah it's one of the many things that
we're working on
now my apologies in advance if this is
already something you guys have launched
uh but if not do you have plans to
provide
I suppose the equivalent of custody for
nfts as opposed to cryptocurrency so for
instance
I know quite a few people I may be one
of them who've collected lots of pretty
jpegs and yeah
the value of some of these makes me very
uncomfortable
uh in terms of just you know having it
hanging in my driveway metaphorically
speaking do you or have any intention of
providing the capability to basically
Safe House store guard nfts themselves
for people who want additional layers of
protection for their portfolios yes and
we we offer this today so
well the first the first app that we
launched it in was coinbase wallet which
is our self-custodial wallet
and that's been an easy way for people
to deal with interact with nfts for
quite a while but as you pointed out
some people may I'm not sure if this
exactly what you're referring to but
some people don't want to have to be
responsible for you know the one
password kind of ruling everything in
their self-custodial wallet yeah and so
we now offer the ability to store nfts
in the main coinbase retail app which is
you know we're storing it on your behalf
and you can do that in our in our we
call it our dap wallet it's kind of a
decentralized app Wallet anyway you can
you can store nfts there
even in coinbase Prime for institutions
we will very soon be able to store nfts
there as well like if you have a family
office or
some of these institutions that now
increasingly want to be storing nfts as
well so lots of good options there and
yeah there's a lot of funny stories in
crypto where somebody
had something on a thumb drive or
whatever and then they they realized you
know I probably shouldn't just be
carrying this around in my backpack I'm
I'm just walking around with you know 40
million dollars in my backpack every day
if it happens to get stolen it's not
good so well yeah there's there's losing
the USB drive we're getting stolen then
there are wrench attacks then there's
all sorts of craziness and I think
there's the and I I respect a lot of
people in this Camp there's the you know
not your keys not your crypto
folks yeah
and uh I think a lot of their arguments
have some validity at the same time
having dealt with death threats and
crazy people and I'm sure you've dealt
with a lot of that once you get a taste
of that experience your appetite for
some degree of self-management goes down
I think yeah and the Really volatile
unpredictability of of some of those
situations becomes a little realer to
each person who experiences it so
just to grab onto that for a second so
there are
they're folks who would be critical of
coinbase as a trusted third party right
and
then there are I think also some some
very compelling arguments to have robust
infrastructure and security protecting
high value assets
where do you think the not your keys not
your crypto arguments have validity and
where do you think they're maybe missing
the forest for the trees or missing
certain aspects of what you're doing
that have
have a real utility that can't be
replicated
in a decentralized way
to be clear we're actually very aligned
with this not your keys not your crypto
crowd as well in the sense that coinbase
wallet is built for them it is a
self-custodial wallet so it's we don't
hold the keys the customer holds the
keys I think that's actually a really
important aspect of crypto because there
is a danger that basically if crypto
gets big enough and too centralized
right and coinbase is one of those
companies that could be storing a lot of
crypto we are
that eventually there could be seizures
or various governments around the world
that we have to interact with who may
you know put our employees in jail or
whatever it's not going to be we I don't
think that's likely but I think just the
fact that it's possible means that you
need to have some kind of escape hatch
if you will or Lifeboat so anyway we we
built coinbase wallet for that exact
purpose
I use it as a customer like everybody
and you know I also use our custodial
app I try to use both and so we want to
make it essentially easy for people to
store their own crypto if they want to
do that I'll come back to sort of the
personal threats you have to deal with
in a second but we also want to make it
easy for people who don't want to have
to worry about that to store it we will
store it on your behalf and I think
we're the best company in the world to
do that we're the most trusted we store
more crypto than anybody else I'm aware
of both for retail customers and
institutions and we've built a lot of
really cool stuff distributed across
many data centers all over the world
where you know I personally don't have
the ability to do it and there's in
consensus mechanisms and there's
Disaster Recovery mechanisms that
contemplate all kinds of things from
nuclear war to natural disasters and you
know whole countries going offline and
things like that so we can do that for
institutions in retail really well and I
think a lot of Institutions they don't
have any interest in self-custody right
I think it's important there was a lot
of debate about this in the crypto
Community for a long long time
and what I came away from it is with
both of these are going to be massive
segments that we need to address we need
to build products for both of them it's
not like an either or it's going to be
both so yeah to win these deals like
with BlackRock and meta to land like the
largest Sovereign wealth funds in the
world and you know Pension funds and
those kinds of customers and I would say
even a large amount of retail customers
we have to have custodial solutions for
them they don't want to have to manage
their own keys
so now coming back to I guess your
original thought about self-custody and
how that'll play out so self-custody is
evolving to a place where I think you
know if you're storing kind of the
amount of money that you would have like
in your physical wallet as you walk
around like that's fine if it's just you
know you're the only one with the
password and you know if you lose it or
you get robbed or whatever it's kind of
like getting robbed on the street it's
unfortunate but it's not like a life
existential thing
and so how are people going to be able
to store
life meaningful amounts of money or
their life savings or whatever and I
think they're going to be able to do it
basically with multi-party computation
or something it's you know multi-sig was
what kind of people called it originally
but there'll be wallets where you know
it's not coinbase doesn't have like a
quorum of the keys but coinbase might
have one key you have another key
there's a backup key with somebody else
that you that you trust right you can
kind of create these like two of three
or three of five type signature schemes
that have redundancy in the event that
one or two of the pieces are lost but it
also prevents any one or two people from
running off with the full amount of
money and I guess in the sense that if
you you know if somebody experiences a
personal security threat they literally
cannot
send the phones at least at least not in
some short time period and it would sort
of get into a situation just like you
would have if your money was at Goldman
Sachs or something like that and you got
kidnapped in Mexico I mean somebody
would probably call them and there'd be
some negotiation or whatever
and so that's the kinds of Technology
that's being developed and coinbase is
sort of building a lot of that into our
coinbase wallet product over time
yeah it's an unfortunate thing there is
a there is a GitHub that Jamison Lop
maintains on all the physical security
threats that have happened with Bitcoin
and it's if you want to go scare
yourself you can go read that luckily a
lot of them haven't happened in the US
but there have been a couple of armed
robberies and things like that law
enforcement in the US is generally
pretty good at cracking down on these
kind of organized crime type things
but yeah it's a new Financial system for
the world people are going to have to
ultimately take responsibility if they
want to do self-custody and I think a
lot of people are going to want to do
that with these new sorts of multi-party
computation tools that have come out
yeah thank you for lying that out
I I suppose I have spooked myself I
haven't read that GitHub repository but
just from a lot of names you would
recognize just chatting with people who
are deeply involved with this space you
don't have to look very far to see some
pretty intimidating examples of of
security threats
let me shift gears and
ask you about
self-improvement so you are very as far
as I can tell
consistent with a focus on
self-improvement
what would you change about yourself or
improve about yourself or what do you
what are you most interested in
improving about yourself at the moment
well you're correct I mean I did I did
get pretty into self-improvement I guess
in my 20s and
read a bunch of books on that and I just
I started to kind of like this idea of
you know whatever you have top of mind
every day you can kind of it's just what
you tend to focus on right so if you're
surrounded by negativity and things like
that you just tend to be more negative
and if you wake up every day and you try
to listen to like some good podcasts or
read some stuff or write down your goals
or your affirmations whatever you can
kind of
you know rewire your brain I'm not I'm
not into like the metaphysical stuff
about it I just think it's more
practical than that it's like all right
what am I choosing to focus on today
right how to even just like get things
done efficiently and uh like David Allen
I think his name is has a good book
getting things done right I mean I
roughly follow some kind of a process
like that and there's a lot of things
I've read like that over the years once
in a while when I'm like you know wake
up in the morning and I I'm like oh I'm
supposed to be exercising but like I
just don't feel like it today and I'm
like I'm being kind of lazy you know my
my best like motivation hack is like
just to type David Goggins into YouTube
and watch a random video
that comes up and then you will you'll
be working out shortly otherwise you
will feel like you know total whim but
you I guess your question was what do I
want to improve about myself right now I
mean so I'm 39 now and just going from
like 29 to 39.
you know I've noticed I'm starting to
feel like I'm getting older right it's
kind of a scary thing right like you
know jet lag affects me more and like if
I get injured it takes longer to recover
and I think even my memory has gotten
like a little bit worse I feel like I
used it used to be my short-term memory
was like really good if people told me
like five or six things I'd be like yeah
I got them all in my head right and now
it's like I'm trying to say think like
two minutes later I'm like what was that
I don't remember what they were really
talking about so
I start to write down a lot more things
so I'm noticing now that yeah ages age
is something where I feel like hey maybe
I only have another 10 20 you know 30
years of like really productive stuff
and what do I want to do with that so I
started to think more about longevity
Health I've gotten I've gotten a lot
more into like
being healthy and even like started a
longevity company or at least it funded
it helped put some money into it
so we can talk more about that later if
you want but trying to think what else
I'm also just trying to
I don't know I'd say the other thing I'm
really focused on is like
I've had some success and some liquidity
with coinbase and so early on I think I
was driven by just like doing something
meaningful in the world and making some
wealth and I've sort of done that and so
I'm basically just driving my motivation
from other things which are like what do
I actually like doing you know which is
like I tend to like learning new things
I like to build things with technology
so I'm trying to make sure that I can
have like really high motivation and
energy for hopefully many decades to
come and keep building more and more
cool stuff
anything in particular you're you're
taking a stab at learning at the moment
I I
re-wound and watched there's a very
maybe half second or one second snippet
in the dock where you're packing a bag
for travel and you have three books I
couldn't identify the one on the bottom
there was I think it was seven days to
the perfect puppy on the top yeah and
then another one that it was hard to
hard to get a full read of but it was
something like the healing brain or the
healing mind
something along those lines I can't
remember the exact title so that may be
a dead end but there was a freeze frame
of it it was the the second book and a
stack of three
anything that you're focused on learning
at the moment or would like to learn in
the next six to 12 months that's funny
actually I haven't seen the final film I
saw like a rough cut of it and I think I
saw that perfect puppy book and I was
there I was like someone's gonna ask me
about that that's funny that's me on cue
we were thinking about getting a dog at
that point but we ended up getting some
cats instead which who knows that maybe
they'll make an appearance behind me
here but yeah so I'm always kind of
reading like books like that
those two in particular were not super
memorable but
I'm trying to think like what else would
be helpful right now I mean I'm I'm
actually I'm like trying to learn more
about biology right now
I started off trying to read some
textbooks on this and there was a couple
books out there that was kind of for
like I basically I never gotten a chance
in college to like really study biology
and I didn't have a specific reason to
but now as I'm learning more about
health I'm like why don't I know more
about biology I kind of wish I did
one thing that I did was I actually
hired a biology tutor so I was trying to
go through these
these textbooks and you know I I was
doing it but it was taking me a long
time like you know a little read like
five minutes every evening and it's not
Light reading yeah I mean it's like it's
no it's no seven days to the perfect
puppy yeah you know you get really
demoralized when you read a sentence
you're like five of those words I have
no idea what they mean you know
it's like one word every couple
sentences okay I can maybe hack through
it but like five words in the first
sentence you're in trouble anyway I
heard grad students are like woefully
underpaid and some of these people are
just like brilliant teachers and so I
asked a few friends of mine and instead
of trying to you know Wade my way
through this super dense textbook every
night it's actually been way more fun I
basically just for an hour on Sundays
usually I meet up with this guy he's
such a great teacher and he can jump
around to kind of teach me like whatever
I'm most interested in you know instead
of having to Wade through the whole book
so that's been a pretty cool hack let's
deep dive on biology what what
context if you provided this tutor
because biology is kind of like physics
right I mean you can go in a million
different directions are you starting
with just the basic basic building
blocks okay what's the Krebs cycle
what's this what's that what are the
essential amino acids how do they factor
into a b and c what what context or
direction did you give your tutor I gave
him the context of I want to learn all
the fundamentals so I don't I at least
know the basics so I don't understand
like a complete baby and the part of the
context was also you know I was those
babies suck at biology that's true
um well this is kind of how I sound when
I try to speak you know Spanish or not I
sound like a five-year-old or whatever
so and then I was also in the process of
like funding this this biotech Company
New limit and we can talk about that
later but that was I was trying not to
sound like an idiot in front of the team
basically
and so yeah the cool thing is he's been
able to not only we went through a bunch
of like Basics around cells and things
like that but we've also started to get
into just like how do people develop
these
Tools in biology like like PCR or flow
cytometry and like you know because in
in a biotech context like we're trying
to leverage the latest tools to of
course Advance the state of the art how
do you sequence these cells now and what
kind of data do you get out or the
latest techniques but he's also kind of
helping me understand the history of a
little bit of this like
well previously everybody used this
technique and that was considered the
state of the art but somebody eventually
at some point had to find a way to do it
like at 10 or 100x throughput and you
know like the Human Genome Project and
how did they finally sequence this thing
which seemed like an insurmountable
project and so I've been getting to
learn a lot about a really cool
history of how people found you know
something that already existed in
biology in some you know
heated pool somewhere and like they sort
of hacked that to do our bidding in some
and anyway that that part has been
really interesting for me to understand
the history of it and how how to try to
advance like put another leaf on the
tree of knowledge that's kind of what
our goal is with the biotech so I'm
going to ask you about new limit I would
strongly encourage
everyone to read more on the history of
science I think
it it would be such an incredible Boon
and gift to everyone involved if more
people read
up on the history of science for a lot
of reasons because you can a
deconstruct how thorny problems or
seemingly insurmountable problems were
tackled successfully which is like a
reading a detective novel in and of
itself a lot of the time and also I
think it is a nice remedy to certain
epistemological arrogance that humans
tend to have like oh well nah there are
a few things left to figure out but we
really have nature pretty much on lock I
think we've got it dialed it's like no
no no no no we really don't so you
should read up just the the amount of
confidence that people have always had
at different points in history with the
most ludicrous
coping mechanisms for like just shoddy
interventions and so on there's there's
no reason to think it's any different
now
so that's also another reason to read up
just to give everybody a dose of kind of
Humble Pie when considering not just
what we know but the possibilities
moving forward
what is the goal of new limit why are
you involved
last year coinbase went public and um
you know it's a good liquidity event for
everybody involved I think actually I
think over like a thousand millionaires
were created in that IPO just from
various employees and investors who had
worked on coinbase over the last 10
years so that was like incredibly
fulfilling and one of the things it
caused me to do is kind of to pause and
think about
all right what do I want to do you know
for the next 10 years 20 years and I was
like I want to I want to continue to be
the CEO of coinbase like that's going to
be my first priority I think we're just
at the very beginning of creating the
open Financial system for the world and
I'm going to keep doing that but I've
got some liquidity now like I want to
try to do something useful with it
because
I think like you know we're kind of in
this golden age of software where like
fortunes are being made and but some of
that wealth even in crypto has now been
is now being directed into hard science
problems like you know atoms not bits
and I think that's a really good thing
actually because it'll probably create a
secondary effect like a boon in these
other areas so I started to host these
dinners basically
with friends of mine that were either
other bio people like biotech experts
CEOs investors or scientists and
especially in this space around you know
like crispr I had read about that and
like car T cells and I was like my
Spider Sense is like there's something
happening in in this area in biology
where it's starting to feel more like
engineering not science where we have
some of these tools to actually go do
unique stuff
so I just started hosting these dinners
randomly and I basically just went
around the room and asked everybody like
what's something you're most excited
about right now and one of the topics
that came out came up like during these
dinners was something called epigenetic
programming of cells
which I can try to give a brief overview
of that if it's helpful yes please okay
well long story short back in 2006
yamanaka got the Nobel Prize for
discovering that you could turn you know
a skin cell back into a stem cell by
exposing it to these four
transcription factors which are just
like proteins that you can expose a cell
to and it it was kind of like a
mind-blowing thing at the time which is
like wow you can really we can change
the cell back to a stem cell and since
then people have been learned that they
can change a cell into other types of
cells so the for instance you could turn
up I don't know like a skin cell into a
neuron cell or a muscle cell or
something like that by exposing it to
different transcription factors so just
in the last five years or so several
Labs have shown that you can basically
you don't want to change the cell State
you don't want to turn it all the way
back to being a stem cell but you can
basically rejuvenate right or move the
cell to sort of a more functional
earlier state by exposing it to some of
these factors we have an existence proof
of this if you will because we know that
some animals in nature can regenerate
right like a salamander like its arm if
it's cut off it'll kind of regrow or
like jellyfish some of them seem to live
indefinitely and
even like human beings I guess like if
you you know if there's like a infant in
a womb and there's like a prenatal
surgery it'll come out there's like no
scars right and so we're seeing Even in
our own human biology there's sort of an
existence proof for some amount of
Rejuvenation capability and so I
basically realized uh this could be an
interesting area to pursue I talked to a
bunch of my smart friends about it
because obviously I'm not I'm not a
scientist in this field which is always
a dangerous thing to go into and so I
partnered with Buyers on this since he's
a PhD in you know he actually is a
scientist and he's started a successful
company before and he as a partner at
Google Ventures he invested in a bunch
of Biotech companies and I basically
decided all right let me try to put some
some money into this with Blake and see
if we can help this company get off the
ground and even if I'm not you know
running it or anything like that I can
probably hopefully help this thing get
off the ground and so yeah new limit is
basically going to try to build a
platform that tests a lot of different
transcription factors with different
cell types and uses machine learning to
do that in a virtuous cycle because it's
a huge search space of complexity that
you could imagine the number of
transcription factors the number of
combinations of it is like you know 10
to the 15th different possibilities and
so you need some sort of way to kind of
do a more directed search through this
giant space and yeah so they've been
able to build an incredible team to date
there's about eight or nine people there
brilliant scientists young people
machine learning folks
with an office in South San Francisco so
if people are interested in that I'd
encourage them to go check out the
website and apply for for a role if
they're interested in the space it's a
new limit and to
try to ensure I understand the basics of
this they're looking at different
sort of combinatorial cocktails of
transcription factors that produce
particular that are
optimal for producing certain types of
changes in cells are they focused on
reversing cell senescence so reversing
let's just say cell aging is that a
primary objective or are they also
looking at productizing in some fashion
the conversion of one type of cell to
another or are they really just
creating the database that will then be
used by other companies
could you explain the business model a
bit right I should have mentioned that
earlier so yeah so the goal of of new
limit is really to radically extend
human health span so the moonshot of the
company is really it's a longevity
company we're trying to help humans live
much longer not just a little bit longer
but I think in any good moonshot company
you know you want to have intermediate
Milestones along the way and so the
intermediate Milestones are more like
could we get a specific type of cell to
be rejuvenated and be younger and sort
of you know an example would be like
older people when they get the coveted
vaccine
they don't have as strong of a response
to it because their T cells are older
they're they're more exhausted so if we
could in some sense rejuvenate T cells
right or you know pulmonary fibrosis is
another issue that affects people maybe
there's a way to rejuvenate those cells
to get them to be younger so oftentimes
people get hung up on this definition of
well what does it even mean aging like
is a cell older or younger and we sort
of
you know don't worry about like some big
fancy rigorous definition we're just
saying we're trying to restore function
in these cells to get them to behave
like younger cells so hopefully we can
find with this platform to test this
rapidly with at a scale that hasn't
really been done before an industrial
scale to test this with different cell
types different tissues basically we'll
hopefully find hits here for different
indications whether that's T cells or
pulmonary fibrosis or others and develop
therapies for that but the ultimate
long-term goal of the company would be
eventually you know some therapy that
you could take that would actually just
help humans live longer in a healthy
state
hypothetically what might administration
of these therapies look like I don't
know enough about the transcriptions
transcription factors to speak
intelligently about them but are these
with these effectively end up as
molecules that are synthesized and put
into a capsule is it some other route of
administration what might that look like
the actual delivery mechanism is a
little bit further down the research
path and it's not the main thing we're
focused on at the moment because we're
basically doing this with human cells in
dishes basically in vitro right but you
can imagine you know mRNA is now
something that we have huge proof point
with with the coveted vaccines and I
think that's a very interesting delivery
mechanism people have looked at there's
there's different viral delivery
mechanisms that people have used more
historically you could even imagine
there may be some cases where uh kind of
like dialysis or something like people
actually get you know cells taken out of
their body they could be then
rejuvenated put back in there's various
things like that which could be
attempted but obviously for like again
the moonshot the long-term goal it would
ideally be something even like it could
be a pill or like a shot that you get
that's something that's more mass Market
so I encourage people to check it out
beautiful website very nicely designed
newlimit.com yeah so easy to remember so
I encourage people to check that out
would you like to describe for people
research Hub uh because I think this is
related or at least overlapping in in
some respects
yeah well okay so thanks for asking I
mean this is another project by the way
you can see the theme in all these which
is I'm really passionate about basically
improving the world with science and
technology that's kind of like the
overarching theme here and I feel like
cryptocurrency was a great breakthrough
for that to create more economic freedom
and some of the dollars I mentioned now
are that are flowing from that industry
into these other areas are helping I
think accelerate scientific research and
it even ties into what we talked about
in the beginning with Ray dalio's book
you know he talks about the changing
World Order like the root of a lot of
progress is basically education which
leads to Science and Technology
Innovation which leads to Unique
Products which leads to economic growth
and then that's how societies Prosper
they have higher GDP they have Surplus
that they can invest in the Arts and
you know culture and you know defense or
whatever they want to invest in so more
universities or education so anyway I I
really think that a lot of people today
this is sort of a tangent but a lot of
people today are thinking like how do I
improve the world like they're in you
know aspiring young person and there's a
temptation to say hey like we should you
know advocate for different government
policies we should go become an activist
or a protester and like I don't know my
message to people this is part of why I
created the documentary as well coin is
I wanted to show people like if you want
to try to impact the world I think one
of the best ways to do it is to build a
company that's based around science and
technology and
so anyway time this all ties back to
research Hub which
is another company that I funded and try
to help try to help get off the ground
so the team bear is doing really awesome
stuff around trying to make scientific
research more like open source software
like like GitHub or something and you
can see all the different challenges
that are out there in the scientific
research space today
there's kind of there's a replication
crisis where a lot of times people are
publishing papers it turns out later
nobody can reproduce it a lot of
scientific research is done in Academia
where it's done in a silo in isolation
because you know they're not actually
getting like the material benefits from
these technologies that are when like if
you invented crispr you should have been
able to help commercialize it and make
you know become a billionaire it's such
a big breakthrough but they're not doing
that they're basically they're basically
only able to get citations and
Publications in tenure and so they're
living in this kind of artificial I
don't know academic environment and so
you get people more siled it takes a
long time to publish a paper they're
basically writing it these small small
Innovations are written up in some big
flowery language it's inaccessible to
the average person
so with research Hub yeah we're trying
to make it easy for people to sort
through all of the you know millions of
papers that are published every year to
what are the most impactful we're trying
to help get things like peer review you
know q a comments feedback around
research to be more collaborative with
people and we're trying to get like data
sets and the code to be published
alongside the papers so it's not just
reading some static PDF and we're trying
to help with things like fundraising for
for science in in the future so there's
actually a coin associated with this
research coin which is a reward coin
that was created that helped in a
governance token that helps the
community sort of get rewarded as they
contribute more and more to that site
and that community so it has like a
really passionate small nascent
Community that's that's helping grow a
lot of the content on the site today and
I think the roadmap board is really
exciting to hopefully just get rid of a
lot of like the barriers to scientific
innovation you know we saw a small
example of this during covid where like
everything went warp speed during covet
to find a vaccine people were publishing
their papers on Twitter instead of going
through like a two-year Journal process
that had all these pay walls and stuff
like that and everything just went
faster that's how it should be all the
time and that's how we can advance
civilization I think so we're trying to
help do that with research Hub as well
yeah we're looking at the website right
now this is quite cool I'm looking at
the front page I have some some
questions about the front page but just
to look at a few things that are
the seemingly popular you've got
long-term health effects of
antidepressant use you've got
alcohol impact on sports performance and
Recovery in male athletes you have
greater Effects by performing a small
number of eccentric contractions daily
than a large number of them once a week
I will probably read that in the next
two hours because that's very of great
interest to me especially for connective
tissue repair
with tendinosis in the elbow now there
are I'm noticing open bounties
could you just explain what these open
bounties
mean to the people who are posting them
and for anyone who might be a bounty
hunter
so this is one of the things that we're
testing out with basically adding a
crypto asset in onto this platform to
try to see if it improves the
collaboration of people there
and so what we did was we allowed
anybody who had
you basically a question a scientific
question or anybody who wanted like a
peer review or maybe they want a video
summary of their paper a task that
people often have even in Private
Industry or in scientific research is
they'll say I want a summary of the
literature I want someone to go out
there read the 20 or 50 most relevant
papers on a certain
scientific question and give me kind of
a meta study aggregate that information
and we're sort of building the tools for
people to do that as well so people can
do that with research coin it's it's a
way to the people who are kind of
contributing the most are earning it
that's improving their reputation on the
site
but it's also a way for people to kind
of get recognized and
you know I always tell people imagine if
like the early hosts on Airbnb or the
early drivers in Uber had gotten a
chance to like participate in the the
network that they helped create and
that's kind of what's coming together
here on Research hub
is the
method of redemption or I guess let me
phrase it a different way the value of
research coin at the moment is one
social credibility and two with the
research coin that you earn you can then
post your own bounties and make requests
of the community are those the sort of
two main values to an individual
contributor who is
accruing research coin yeah that's
correct okay got it
what has you most excited so let's
pretend the year at one of these dinners
you're hosting and I said look I know
you're not a biologist I understand that
however you've crossed the you know
speaking like a five-year-old point you
seem to have a good grasp of the basics
you also have an engineer's mind which I
would argue is more similar to top-end
Scientific Minds than one might think I
I think the disciplines are different
but the mental Frameworks the ability to
ask questions attempting to replicate
Etc transfer quite well what are you
most excited about
in the world of science
just think about all the biggest
challenges that we have in the world
today
I think Science and Technology are like
pretty good hammers to swing at those
Nails you know it's like okay we've got
climate change right everyone's talking
about climate change so
I mean I think Fusion Energy is super
exciting I think people working on
carbon sequestration is pretty
interesting you've got you know again
Elon is kind of working on that with
with Tesla and solar panels and electric
vehicles and as our arivian and all
these other companies to me those are
the most promising Solutions we have to
that are using technology right if you
look at education it's like Khan Academy
stuff like that gets me really excited
it's like okay let's make a free
world-class education available to
everyone that's really cool right if you
look at
why don't we have you know better
economic you know Financial
infrastructure in all the countries of
the world and why do we have a big
inflation problems and why is it cost
two percent every time you swipe your
credit card you know it takes forever to
move money around the world and like
crypto is is a really important solution
to that which is basically a science and
technology breakthrough right so
I kind of feel like
I don't know if this is exactly what you
were asking but I just feel like
science and technology and building
commercializing it is like the thing
that is really the most exciting thing
there's another thought I've had is like
there's kind of two very different
worlds so there's one world of
scientists and academics and there's
another world of entrepreneurs and they
actually very rarely do they
cross-pollinate most people who are
entrepreneurs they're making something
that's like mostly based around
marketing it's like a new tequila with a
celebrity or whatever or like you know
and then most scientists are building
things which never get commercialized
like because they're living in a pure
academic world but if you think about a
lot of the most valuable companies in
the whole world Genentech right SpaceX
even coinbase which was based on a
research paper the Bitcoin research
paper right it's basically even Google
was came out of like a basically a
research project at Stanford with the
Larry and Sergey right and like so the
most valuable companies in the world are
when we cross-pollinate a true
scientific innovation with someone who
can go commercialize it and the problem
is these two groups of people are like
sometimes oil and water like the
scientists don't like people who make
money and they think it's like kind of
low integrity and you know the business
people don't have any understanding of
science whatsoever and they basically
get caught up in pseudoscience and all
these things and so anyway I think the
more you can cross-pollinate and get
those two areas to talk to each other
the few the few people in the world who
can speak both languages like a
translator they know enough business to
be dangerous and enough science to be
dangerous those are going to be really
valuable things that get credit for all
Humanity
sounds like you might be one of those
people
that's why I'm uh doing the biology
tutor yeah I might have to pick up on
this biology tutoring idea
I could also use some some basic
groundwork unless I get myself into
trouble so last question or second or
last question and this may be a dead end
I'll take the blame if it is but I like
to ask this one
the metaphorical billboard question so
if you could put a message or a quote
image anything non-commercial on a
billboard to get the message out to
let's just say billions of people
assuming they speak whatever language is
on the billboard what might you put on
that billboard
I guess there was one we said earlier
which was like action produces
information I like that one a lot but if
I had to pick a second one since we
already said that one of my favorite
sayings is the greatest risk is not
taking one and
I feel like a lot of people they have
ideas
they just debated endlessly they never
take that first step and there's really
a scarcity of risk tolerance and I don't
I don't mean like doing anything that's
like
actually that risky in fact I think you
put out like a great framework um a
while back about sort of imagining what
is really the worst thing that's going
to happen and could you actually live
with that right it's like starting a
company I mean okay so you went and
raised some money and what's the worst
thing that happens I mean it's basically
the company fails you shut it down maybe
you go get another job you know and if
you raised a little bit of seeded
Capital you can probably pay yourself
during that time period so like is it
really that big of a deal I mean if you
know if that's truly the worst case
scenario then like what's stopping you
right so you know everybody has their
own unique personal situations maybe
it's harder for them than others like so
I don't I don't mean to belittle any of
that but oftentimes the fears that
people have it's it's greater in their
own mind than it is in reality so yeah
greatest risk is not taking one maybe
I'd put that out there
I dig it well Mr Armstrong
maybe someday Dr Armstrong biologist PhD
astrophysicist uh is there anything else
you would like to add before we wind
this to a close any any closing comments
requests of my audience
things to point attention to public
complaints you'd like to Lodge anything
at all
no I mean I guess mostly just want to
say thank you I think you're one of the
group people out there that you're
really celebrating Builders which is
people who are trying to do ambitious
stuff in the world you know they don't
always succeed but at least they're
trying and
I think frankly there's like too much
too many people out there want to be a
Critic and poke holes and everything and
it's easy to be a Critic it's actually
easy way to sound smart but it's hard to
do difficult things and I think you're
encouraging people to do that you've
done that yourself
and I I I'm just glad that there is like
New Media out there you know which I
consider you to be part of that podcasts
and blogs and YouTube and
kind of like this documentary coin as
well
that we're trying to participate in this
new media movement to sort of let's go
celebrate Builders you know let's tell
the behind the scenes stories of
the ups and the Downs The Good Bad and
The Ugly
and so I appreciate you being a part of
that and uh yeah I hope people go check
out the documentary it's called coin and
I I partly I created it because I wanted
to show people what it's like to try to
create something new in the world going
from your laptop you know to being a
public company and sort of demystify it
and hopefully more people will watch it
and say hey you know what I could do
that
I want I want people to go create more
companies in the world so hopefully
that'll happen
well thanks thanks for the kind words
man I really appreciate it and coin can
be found on Amazon iTunes Vimeo on
demand other platforms
one final question related to the
documentary what's the story with are
they dinosaur pajamas
I saw it come up multiple times like the
onesie pajamas yeah what is the
background there oh man you know
sometimes when you when I made this
documentary I was like so I'm either
gonna look like an idiot or this is
going to be great but either either way
I'm going to try it um so that's one of
those moments where I probably look like
an idiot but yeah in the early days
building coinbase I mean
it was literally just like 12 hours a
day kind of like you know try to write
some code talk to customers and I was
for whatever reason I thought this this
onesie was just hilarious I had it
around the house so it was kind of It
kind of became uh like I never thought
it would turn up in a documentary I'll
guarantee you that but um I think I wore
it to a couple hackathons we had at the
coinbase office too so you know you got
to keep it fun have fun while you're uh
trying to do crazy stuff yeah the
coinbase team mascot uniform I dug it I
was just I had to ask I wasn't sure if
that was like a formal attire for board
meetings or something else well Brian
thank you so much for making the time
and for being so game for the
conversation people can find you on
Twitter at Brian underscore Armstrong
and we will link to everything including
the new documentary and all the books
resources names companies Etc that we've
discussed people can find in the show
notes at tim.blog slash podcast
and until next time everybody be a
little Kinder than as necessary and
remember the greatest risk is not taking
one be safe out there